let's go next to
Bodhi is it pronounced Bodhi from New
Orleans or body
yes it's it's Bodhi from New Orleans
thanks so much it's like from Point
Break Patrick Swayze yes uh your your
Discord is already blinging so we're
kind of hanging by a thread here on
keeping you on but what's on your mind
today
hey David thanks so much for taking my
call I just recently watched um an
interview from
from uh the forward party from Andrew
Yang I wanted to ask but I don't really
trust that he and his coach are the
former Republican Governor from New
Jersey I don't think they have a mind to
bring it to the presidency but they did
talk about focusing more on local life
and stuff like City councilmen uh local
city politics so I wanted to ask what
you thought about not just support party
but about bringing American politics
more to local politics so instead of
just party affiliations like Democrat
Republican making maybe making new
parties or just voting for people who
are Independents in that sense 100 on
the local importance of local elections
I have voted in different local
elections during my life in different
places I've lived which were
non-partisan elections people don't
declare a party they doesn't mean they
aren't Democrats or Republicans or or
whatever but they don't declare a party
and you actually have to hopefully
figure out what they're about I think
that that's great as far as the forward
party we reviewed earlier in the week
the interview that and Andrew Yang did
on CNN with Jim Acosta it was really bad
for Andrew Yang it's just like what are
the positions of the forward party it
does that he they're not saying them and
because it's Democrats and Republicans
and he says we're taking the common
sense consensus positions but he won't
say what they are it's not forward
party's not doing it for me focusing at
the local level
and doing non-partisan local elections
I'm with you a hundred percent
I completely agree I saw that exactly
that's what I was talking about after
the German class interview yeah I got
that that's an impression from too now
let me ask you because you you you might
know more about the forward party than I
do is there a position they have
outlined on any specific issue
I will say that so their motto seems to
be right now that they have three
primary components on policies right so
first is representative rank Choice
voting that's like their biggest thing
number two is I believe it's gun control
in some sort Common Sense controller
okay and they have taken a Civic and
significant position on the election
saying that it wasn't stolen okay it
seems that it's not exactly the most
courageous thing to say one of our big
pillars is the election wasn't stolen
but okay I mean at least it's something
right I think that the entire model of
just having these three ideas and just
not setting any points at all yeah is
quite nebulous and stuff but thanks so
much for taking my call I appreciate it
my pleasure there's Bodie from New
Orleans great to hear from you glad to
have the opportunity to chat about that
yeah we spoke about it earlier and it
was it was all kind of a little weird